wir gehen mal von oben nach unten warum
nicht einfach verarscht die haben gesagt
es ist 9.30 was ist das höchstens 37
wahrscheinlich etwas gedacht bretts
willkommen bei einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut mir auf
ja und zwar bin ich letztes mal auf die
idee gekommen ich war bei mir zu hause
also nicht in köln sondern das andere
zuhause zu hause das macht eigentlich
sind wenn man sagt ich war zuhause zu
hause in seinem zuhause was haben gerade
mal 32 prozent von den leuten in dieses
video schon abonniert deswegen abonniert
auf jeden fall den kanal oder wir waren
wir alle zusammen in einem second hand
geschäft weil keine ahnung da gab es zu
allen möglichen krims krams und es gab
auch wirklich eine menge klamotten und
ich habe mir gedacht wenn es da schon so
viel gibt musste ihr einen köln
eigentlich noch mehr geben natürlich
waren viele sachen da nicht schön ein
paar sachen waren aber auch gut also ich
von liefern die kann man tragen müssen
wenn ich mal gespannt und ich habe mir
jetzt hier in köln überlegt fährst du
doch einfach mal zusammen second hand
geschäft und kaufte ein outfit
allerdings nicht für mich sondern für
mich das habe ich jetzt gerade gemacht
ich würde sagen hier mal ein kurzer
ausschnitt von außen
leute ich bin so dumm als ich mit der
anderen aufnahme angefangen habe hatte
ich ja das was ich euch eigentlich jetzt
zeigen wollen schon aufgenommen ich
formatiert wenn man vor jedem dreh eine
speicherkarte hatte total vergessen dass
das schon drauf ist das heißt wir haben
jetzt nur noch ein paar handyaufnahmen
dabei wünsche ich euch viel spaß aber
wirklich so in diesem blog stil den ich
eigentlich gemacht hab ich ärger mich
gerade selber extrem aber das ist leider
alles weg ich kann nichts machen viel
spaß
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück
ich habe jetzt insgesamt 30 euro bezahlt
habe 4
robert nämlich oberteile vier klamotten
stücke und ein paar schuhe gekauft okay
allerdings habe ich so praktisch zwei
outfits in vier teilen kombinieren wir
haben einen t shirts oder blusen planen
was das genau ist dann haben wir eine
jacke
dann haben wir eine normale hosen und
dann haben wir noch so eine hot pants
globig heißt es ich weiß nur nicht ob
dir passiert weil keine ahnung da schon
dinge keine größe drin hast was nicht
auch vorher noch gar nicht nach den
größen gefragt deswegen bin ich noch so
gespannt bist du noch so eingespannt bin
ich noch gespannter ab vor allen dingen
in dosen er richtige größe gefunden hat
ja und ich würde sagen wie lange
schlange wenn ihr die idee gut findet
und sagt marie so laufen wir so ein
outfit für mich kaufen das auf jeden
fall mal daumen nach oben da bei
wievielen 120 tagen fast liebst du
hinterm mond sagen 8000 okay ich würde
sagen ich zeige dir erstmal alle teile
ganz in ruhe auf euch und dann probieren
wir die gleiche machen okay wir fangen
wir mit der hose an
die habe ich für 8 euro 50 gekauft die
war glaube ich aber noch mal um 50
prozent reduziert juni war sie doch
nicht 98 hat diese hose gekostet
die wird hier bestimmt gut stehen weil
du ja auch mehrere solche hosen hast
deswegen habe ich die gekauft für acht
euro neuen sicher schön das mal
anschauen
so machen wir noch weiter mit der
anderen hose da weiß ich jetzt nicht so
zusagt sie habe ich einfach mal
mitgenommen
jetzt lasse ich nicht von es ist keine
hose das ist noch so ein rock genauso
aus wie hot pants aber ist mir so was
hast du das hat drei euro 90 kostet
waren noch mal um 50 prozent reduziert
also ein euro 95 oder ja ich habe
schnell gerechnet meinte das passt ihr
oder ist alles umweltfreundliche ja das
ist alles öko dass auch auswiesen
meinst du das tor ein
ich glaube
also rein passen auf jeden fall glaubt
höchstens dass es vielleicht ein
bisschen groß ist an ist aber mal
schauen vielleicht irre ich mich auch so
machen wir weiter
was denn das ist gut mit einem
deutschland das hatte habe ich sofort
zugegriffen
hier komme auf das hat gerade mal zwei
euro gekostet das ging so weit dass
liegen sogar bei der ein euro abteilung
hier findest du ja ich finde das gut
schreibt gerne in die kommentare wie
findet ihr das für einen euro kann man
noch nicht meckern schatten gehen und
dann kriegst du schöne sache in ordnung
ja aber das ist bei primark ja der von
der qualität her absolut schlecht und da
möchte ich auch gar nicht unterstützen
wir das produziert und das hier ist ja
an sich wahrscheinlich auch vom trainer
so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt jetzt
kommt was das hat bestimmt vorher mal 60
euro gekostet ich habe es jetzt glaube
ich für vier euro gekauft und zwar so
eine jacke die man gut rüber werfen kann
fand ich eigentlich richtig gut habe ich
auch sofort genommen
das kann man jetzt hier gar nicht so
beurteilen wie das aussieht aber hier
haben wir sechs euro um 50 prozent
reduziert also 3 euro
vielleicht 60 euro kosten ja das sieht
doch gut aus
neu ist das zwar nicht so teuer so also
lasst noch das heißt ich hatte dafür 15
euro bezahlt für diese vier sachen ich
finde da kann man echt nich meckern dann
habe ich natürlich noch mal schon
ausschau gehalten und habe schon
gegründet von bent 15 euro ich weiß
nicht ob dir passen aber ich denke mal
39 so habe ich sogar auch die hast du
auch ein nein hast du dich oder ich
aktiver kirchen schwarz hey ich hab ich
noch nie gesehen
die hab ich auch schon weiß ich wie
lange ich noch mal die an second hand
laden verkauft das sind wir schon da
diese schuhe kommen noch hinzu
haben 15 aud gekostet da habe ich
wirklich gedacht riechen wie neu da habe
ich erst gedacht
kaufst du dir jetzt für 15 euro oder
schaut nochmal weiter aber da habe ich
einmal meinen geldbeutel gegriffen und
die auch gleich mitgenommen und die tüte
hat mich auch nochmal 30
wir gehen einfach mal ins wohnzimmer und
du darfst das mal anprobieren und ich
bin wirklich sehr gespannt was das wird
ja nein das ist 39 wie ist denn generell
dass man das wäre jetzt echt ein
rückschlag für mich wenn das scheiße
aussieht und ich habe mir wirklich im
laden gedacht war das ist hasse richtig
gut gemacht was hier auf die passenden
farben geachtet wir haben eine hose die
ist in der gleichen farbe wie die jacke
wir haben ein schwarzes t shirt ist
überein stimmt mit der farbe der schuhe
willst du noch irgend einen kommentar
abgeben bevor du raus kommt die hose
habe ich mir irgendwie anders
vorgestellt und in die schule kommst du
nicht rein
ja wenn du willst kannst du jetzt
rauskommen
[Musik]
warte mal ich muss mal kurz kommen
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe mir
das anders vorgestellt
ich dachte nämlich die rose wer so ein
bisschen lockerer und das t shirts ist
ganz anders wie sie ist wirklich aussehe
zweitklässlerin und wir gehen mal von
oben nach unten da wo nicht einfach
verarscht die haben gesagt dass es 39
was ist das höchstens 37 wahrscheinlich
drehte ich noch einmal vielleicht warte
man die jacke fehlt natürlich noch dann
will ich würde sagen das ist wirklich
schlecht dass auch wieder das tut mir
leid da habe ich falsch auch meine mode
skills vertraut beim csv die ak also
jetzt kommt meine geheimwaffe aber und
zwar der rock- und die jacke das muss
gut sitzen dann bin ich mir sicher
[Musik]
oder rot passt ja sogar ist er zu groß
was hast du gedacht hat immer bleibt mal
genau bleiben also stehen
hier muss man jetzt sagen ich finde das
habe ich richtig gut gemacht ich finde
das match sich voll zusammen was hältst
du jetzt von dem autor dass das besser
als andere finde ich auch jetzt mal das
hochgerechnet zusammen da sind wir bei
maximal acht euro
du willst es nicht tragen
nein also ich glaube das glaube ich
schon dass ich das bin ich glaube
nämlich du hast einfach nur keine ahnung
davon
man könnte ich auch übernehmen
nun laden da warte mal da ist recht dass
das urteil könnte man ja
doch nochmal bitte kurz die hacker an
führenden abschließende zusammen l foto
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin
etwas enttäuscht ich auch nein lass dir
gegeben
ich habe mir das wirklich besser
vorgestellt eigentlich schreibt gerne in
die kommentare vielleicht von note eins
bis zehn
was sagt ihr zum ersten outfit was sagt
ihr zum zweiten outfit ich finde aber
dafür dass es wirklich günstig war kann
man jetzt mal wenn ich dich so auf der
straße sehen will und ich vorher noch
nie gesehen habe würde ich sogar sagen
pass auf finde ich gut
erst jetzt ich möchte abschließend dazu
sagen mädels es gibt mit sicherheit
secondhand läden wo es richtig top
sachen gibt also mega und was ich auch
immer lohnt ist auf mädchen flohmärkte
zu gehen weil das ist ja wie eine art
secondhand und da gibt es richtig coole
sachen und was ich auch noch sagen
wollte ja ganz viele klamotten von mir
die ich selber nicht mehr so trage
natürlich kann man die zur
kleidersammlung bringen habe ich auch
schon sogar zum teil ja wie du lädst wie
du eben einfach irgendwelche schuhe von
mir er hat einfach irgendwelche schuhe
von mir die ihm nicht gefallen haben zur
kleidersammlung gebracht und ja da darf
sich da wusste ich nämlich gar nicht die
konnte ich nicht zuordnen da habe ich
dir einfach mitmachen eigentlich habt
ihr eine idee was ich mit den sachen
machen kann schreibt es gern meine
kommentare anders würde ich sagen wir
sehen uns sonntag wieder gibt es neues
video abonnieren nicht vergessen auf
jeden fall das haben gerade mal 32
prozent von den leuten dieses video
schon abonniert deswegen abonniert auf
jeden fall den kanal oder der haut rein
bis sonntag folgt gerne auf instagram